Anna: hey, uh, nice to meet you. I am Anna.
Brandi: hey, sorry if I have to ask all your names again.
Chloe: Oh my god, me too.
Emily: To begin with, I forget a name as soon as I hear it.
Emily: Huh, what's her name? I do not know anymore! (laughs)
Anna: Oh, I have a good trick for that.
Cloe: Oh yeah?
Anna: Yes, you just have to remember that you tell the person's name while you shoot him in the head.
Brandi: ... what?
Anna: Yes, pay attention. Uhm, what's your name?
Brandi: Uh, Brandi.
Anna: Brandi ... (echo)
(pistol shot)
Chloe: (gilt) Emily: (gilt)
(scream)
Brandi: Did you just shot me in the head imaginary?
Anna: Yes.
Anna: And I will remember your name all my life, Brandi.
Chloe: I don't know ... That's pretty weird.
Emily: It sounds a bit psychotic to be honest.
Brandi: Yes, I don't know if I like people killing me imaginary, just to remember my name.
Anna: Oh, well I read it in a book.
Everyone: Ohhhhhh. Brandi: Chill, chill, chill, books are chill.
Emily: You read! That is surprising.
Chloe: That actually makes it pretty cool.
Anna: Yes right?
Emily: Okay, my turn. Uhm what's your name?
Chloe: Chloe!
Emily: Chloe ... (echo)
(pistol shot)
Emily: Brandi .... (echo)
Emily: Anna ... (echo)
(pistol shot)
Brandi: Okay okay, now I do
Brandi: You?
Emily: Emily!
Brandi: Emily ... (echo)
(pistol shots)
Brandi: Chloe ... (echo)
Brandi: Anna ... (echo)
(pistol shots)
Chloe: Oh my god, this is super fun! Let's meet more people.
Anna: (giggles) I'm Anna Akana
Anna: What is your name?
(pistol shot)